so most of you will be pleased to know
that today's video is a happy video
about man's best friend
the hellhound the kind of like man's
best friend except sometimes they may
kill you so I guess they're not really
man's best friend many of you may be
familiar with the term hellhound which
basically refers to a supernatural dog
they can be found in folklore from all
around the world now because of the
obvious association with Hell there is
the belief that all hellhounds are evil
and this is not the case and in today's
video we'll go over to different types
of hellhounds and the roles they perform
in regards to appearance how hounds
pretty much appear as you'd imagine they
have dark black mangled fur that
sometimes appears to even be charred the
eyes glow a menacing crimson color and
some are even completely engulfed in
flames which is most common amongst
cultures that associate fire with the
afterlife now exactly what a hellhound
does can vary some are assigned as guard
dogs protecting the entrances to the
land of the dead these entrances often
include graveyards burial grounds or
literal gates in some stories in other
stories they act as a divide between the
supernatural world and our own keeping
creatures and mythical beings secret
there are also of course hellhounds that
a charge of bringing back souls from the
underworld endlessly pursuing their
victim until they have torn them to
pieces one of the most famous examples
of a hellhound that exists in mythology
is Cerberus the three-headed hound that
guards the entrance to the Greek
underworld
we've mentioned that not all hellhounds
mean harm and we see that with Cerberus
who not only guards the entrance to the
underworld but also guides the dead to
the afterlife now quite a few people
have previously asked me to cover some
British mythology because it's something
that's somewhat faded from existence
you'll be pleased to know that the
legend of the hellhound is something
that is common across Great Britain we
first travelled to Wales to take a look
at their interpretation of a hellhound
at the corner there were a spectral
hound that for the most part was
considered to be benign they may have a
ghostly white appearance but their ears
were red this states back to the Celts
who considered red to be a color
associated of death they would
eventually be nicknamed the dogs of Hell
as it was believed if you were to hear
their howl then death would soon follow
the black shock is a type of hellhound
that is found along the English
coastline in Suffolk Norfolk and Essex
hey there are local tales of a large
black dog the size of a horse it has
eyes that resemble fire and oddly enough
there are stories of the black shark
appearing as headless the majority of
stories describe Encounters of the Black
Rock is terrifying but rarely deadly it
haunts graveyards crossroads and dark
forests some stories described the black
shock at scaring its victims to within
an inch of death and then leaving them
alone to continue an ordinary life as if
it takes enjoyment from other people's
fear there are some stories however
where it is more benign
it would appear only during the evening
and accompany lone women ensuring that
they get home safely the stories and
legends of the black shock have existed
in English countryside for over a
thousand years and for those Sherlock
Holmes fans out there there was a good
chance that the black shock was the
inspiration for the legend that we see
in the Hound of the Baskervilles stain
in Britain we now head to Yorkshire
where there are tales of a hellhound
that goes by the name of the bark hest
this is a monstrous black dog with huge
claws and enormous teeth this hound is
far from benign it prefers to prey on
lone travellers and needless to say
these travelers would never be heard
from again after an encounter with a bog
hessed
and the bark esters are thought to be
capable of shape-shifting assume in
several different forms a headless man
capable of vanishing into flames a
headless woman a black dog a rabbit and
for some reason a white cat the notion
of hellhounds appearing as ghosts and
even shapeshifters is actually one
that's quite common throughout Great
Britain in northern England there are
tales of a trickster like Hound known as
the Gytrash
this is a black dog that would lurk
around the roads waiting for travelers
haunting them and leading them astray it
was believed that they could appear as
horses mules and dogs and if you were to
come across one whose eyes were glowing
like burning coals and it's believed
their intentions were evil this was
considered quite important because there
were tells of the Gytrash where they
would guide lost travelers back to
safety so the eyes were then used as a
way to distinguish between a spirit that
wanted to help you and one that wanted
to kill you there is a type of how harm
that was believed to have been a spirit
of the church and these appeared in both
Scandinavian and English folklore they
often looked after and overseed the
overworld being of a particular Church
these hounds were referred to as a
church grimm and they appeared to be
much smaller in size than the hell
hounds that we've previously discussed
they were also believed to have enjoyed
loud noises and ringing bells which
could be another reason why they were
attracted to churches if we now move
away from Scandinavian folklore
and into Norse mythology we now have our
next exam for the hell happened
gone the guardian of the gates of Hell
garm is often described as being either
a wolf or a dog but quite similar to
Cerberus they both guard the gates to
hell or the afterlife overall hellhounds
can be quite an
spag they can appear as wild animals
protectors guides and even tricksters
the term hellhound is quite broad it can
refer to all manner of creatures but
they're most commonly recognized as
large dogs with black fur and eyes that
glow a menacing shade of red if you're
familiar of any hellhounds from other
cultures and feel free to share them
with me in the comments below as always
I've been your host mythology in fiction
explained